[Musique]
au canada thanks giving été fêté le 11
octobre
là aussi alors qu'il y avait une
stabilisation du nombre d'infections
le nombre de cas a recommencé à grimper
après cette date il ya une région
française où cela va beaucoup mieux au
niveau de l'épidémie c'est la martinique
fini le confinement la situation sur
l'île le père mais annonce le préfet de
région fini les attestations de
déplacement place à un couvre-feu à
partir de ce soir je suis le gars qui
vous volent noël pour vous protéger
j'espère que dans les années à venir
vous ne respecterait pas avoir eu le
courage de vous dire la bonne chose à
faire ici la soirée du nouvel an se
terminer finalement un peu plus tôt que
prévu pour éviter un rebond des
contaminations avec les fêtes
l'exécutif réfléchit à des restrictions
le soir du 31 décembre avec un
couvre-feu par exemple pays le plus
strict autour de nous c'est l'italie où
le gouvernement a clairement sacrifier
noël et le jour de l'an pour éviter la
troisième vague les 25 et 26 décembre et
le 1er janvier tous les déplacements
seront interdits en dehors de la commune
de résidence
et moi je demande au gouvernement que
plutôt que de nous créer des angoisses
ils nous proposent des mesures efficaces
c'est ça le sujet parce que je sais
c'est au moment où j'ai dit depuis le
début
rappelez vous un les masses est très
utile maintenant les masques c'est utile
d'après une source proche de l'exécutif
il n'est pas question d'empêcher les
français de se réunir à noël le
gouvernement tranchera demain matin lors
d'un conseil de défense à l'elysée
est ce que vous dites aux gens qui nous
regardent bah écoute et peut-être qu'il
fera qu'on renonce ou fête de famille
bien sûr renoncer peut-être pas mais en
tout cas prendre des gestes de prudence
je sais que personnellement sera à noël
beaucoup moins nombreux que d'habitude
c'est un besoin collectif mais
infantiliser les gens je trouve que
c'est profondément c'est insupportable
on veut quoi on veut faire déprimer
encore un peu plus les français
on veut casser notre économie la mettre
par terre elle est déjà passée en mal en
point donc faisons attention
mais passons nous passeront noël en
famille avec le chiffre qui a été
indiqué par le gouvernement qui est un
chiffre indicatif qui est une incitation
à la responsabilité et je pense que
chacun
aujourd'hui l'a compris et si on est
capable de faire cela alors on pourra
passer de bonnes fêtes de noël en
famille en tout cas je ne vois pas de
contre indication à cela aujourd'hui
margairaz green 91 ans dans une semaine
elle est la première personne au monde à
recevoir une dose du vaccin
feiler bio ntech j'ai toujours pas vu
une publication scientifique qui
correspond à ces vaccins
donc moi me vacciner avec des produits
que je ne connais pas dont gène un
déjeuner d'information que par les
communiqués de presse des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
c'est quand même leur faire une
confiance aveugle et absolue le deuxième
patient à recevoir le vaccin ça ne
s'invente pas cette même nom juste le
deuxième parce qu'il s'appelle william
shakespeare vraiment le sens de la
dramaturgie et attendons les
autorisations de mise sur le marché
parce que pour l'instant c'est avec ça
qui est intervenu très très vite quand
même donc c'est inhabituel
j'écoute défiance du côté des français
les vaccins et rennes ont été testés il
ya vingt ans chez l'animal c'est pas du
tout une surprise sortie du chapeau en
2020 deuxièmement les essais cliniques
ils ont été les premiers réalisé il ya
douze en 2008 et donc on n'est pas du
tout devant quelque chose qu'on nous a
inventé en janvier 2010 c'était très
intéressant de pouvoir parler avec
l'iran à propos du vaccin qu'elle vient
tout juste de prendre
elle a 81 ans et cette incroyable de
pouvoir entendre qu'elle fait ça pour
l'angleterre et c'est tout à fait vrai
elle se protège et en même temps elle
aide à protéger tout le pays à l'heure
actuelle dans les accords
les laboratoires se sont défaussés de
leur responsabilité individuelle
je suis favorable moi même je me ferai
vacciner je suis favorable à la
vaccination
mais dans la transparence et dans la
responsabilisation les industriels
imaginez
qui n'est pas été tué ce 8 décembre 1980
au roi mois en a mais la star ne serait
peut-être pas devenu légende mais il
aurait 80 ans aujourd'hui
[Musique]